ya es semifinalista de esta edición de
Roland garros tras ganar su partido ante
Karen hashtag el ruso que había
comenzado bastante bien el encuentro se
llevó el primer set es la primera manga
que concede Novak Djokovic en esta
edición de la torneo muchísimos errores
bastante inusuales por parte del cabeza
de serie número tres pero luego sacó a
relucir su buena tenis supo ir
remontando y aprovechar también el
desgaste físico por parte de Karen para
quedarse con este partido de tres horas
cuarenta minutos en parciales de cuatro
seis siete seis seis cuatro y seis dos
Ahora yo cubich está esperando al
ganador del partido entre Carlos Alcaraz
y Stefano
en esa semifinal el partido entre el
español número uno del mundo y el cabeza
de serie número cinco el griego Pues
será esta noche con ese partidazo
terminaremos la jornada de rolandia Rosa
aquí en París También tenemos Resultados
ya tenemos las dos primeras
semifinalistas en el cuadro femen no se
trata de Carolina mojova la checa que
venció a Anastasia pauluchenkova
jugadora rusa finalista aquí en la 21 y
la otra semifinalista es harina
zabalenca una de las grandes favoritas
para llevarse este toreo torneo que
venció a la ucraniana el inas vitolina
en
126464 harina zavalenca que va con paso
firme no solamente a llevarse este
torneo sino también a quedarse con el
puesto de número uno mundial de ahí que
y garciante tiene absolutamente que
hacer todo para clasificar mañana a la
semifinal de este torneo si quiere En
todo caso seguir en la lucha por ser y
mantenerse como la número uno mundial